après les pays-bas la belgique est le
deuxième pays européen a décidé de
dépénaliser la détention et la
consommation de cannabis pour usage
personnel
sa commercialisation reste interdite
agnès gare des adeptes du pétard celui
terre ou en famille géraldine soutien à
la réforme en cours
elle jubile même une réforme qui est en
train d'aboutir
le gouvernement belge en effet planche
sur un texte de loi qui viserait à
dépénaliser la consommation de cannabis
la fin d'un tabou 10e milito mais c'est
insuffisant il faut aussi selon le
légaliser la vente de ces drogues douces
un problème que l'on peut l'imaginer
c'est que on risque à un moment comme on
paie comme ça existe déjà maintenant
d'avoir le vendeur acquis et on
demandera quelques grammes de cannabis
pour la consommation personnelle et
kidira nombre désolé l'âge en dit plus
mais tiens j'ai joué ici de l'héroïne et
c etait deja c'est bien mais on peut
contourner le problème rétorque que la
ministre de la santé à qui l'on doit ce
vent de réformes
elle donne d'ailleurs la solution rien
n'interdit la possibilité de se graver
des sages ravitailler je dirais fût-ce
en cultivant une ou deux plantes soi
même non bruxelles ne sera jamais
amsterdam entre la prohibition et la
vente libre des ministres belges ont
choisi sans surprise la voie du
compromis